I was out here at the Eastern pad but
that's 50 miles east from where we found
him Hey
do you know where your parents are your
family I guess he was on a picnic or a
camping trip he wandered off he got
himself lost I've been out in the woods
doing things his own way sounded like a
boy after your own heart how long has he
been out there six years nobody could
survive in that force for six years he's
not alone
you see I have Elliot who's Elliot
you need to get back down he gets
carefully gone is Elliott person no he
looks like a dragon
what's the dragon Shh
that's a dragon
you don't have to run anymore Pete you
can stay with us this thing is dangerous
don't believe you
come looking for you what's gonna happen
to Elliot you have no idea what this
thing is capable of let's go honey
you're very brave did you know you might
be the bravest boy I've ever met
attention all units
eastbound Mill Haven Road in pursuit of
a dragon it's a dragon you can't say
drag it over the radio
trails in this town how long has he been
out there six years you don't survive in
a forest for six years hello